welcome back to las vegas now being a
raiderette is so vegas but how can you
join the squad allow me to show you and
let's just say i traded in my mic for
some pom-poms for this one check it out
it's time to rally for the raiderettes
the raiderettes are ready to welcome new
rookies to dazzle the sidelines and what
does that require besides rhythm someone
who is poised confident and talented if
you're 21 years of age or older
you could be in the running to become a
raiderette squad director and former
raider at herself tiffany mcniff says
the upcoming auditions are not just
about dance they're about being the best
version of yourself so our first day of
auditions will just be a quick
introduction of yourself
after that you'll dance three or five at
a time learning a quick combination that
we taught prior to coming in
and then after that there will be a
panel interview throughout the week
you'll learn new choreography and at
finals there'll be an onstage question
in addition to your solo and the routine
that you learned that week and the most
frequently asked question football's
most fabulous females receive
do you have to have prior dance
experience in order to audition
and the answer is
no you have to have a willing to learn
and just be a hard worker and someone
who naturally
has a rhythm we've had a lot of
applicants register online to do so you
just go to raiders.com backslash
raiderettes friday april 8th is the
registration deadline for the auditions
next week so
i better get warmed up
ready okay we're gonna teach you two
eight counts of one of our sidelines two
eight counts two eight counts okay stand
still just dance you have to have the
right stance pop that pop that toe
hands on your hips and you're gonna walk
one
two okay so one
i'm already looking
lord
one two we just got a little bounce in
your step though
in your step okay i need to i need to
put my step five six seven eight one two
yes
okay
one
two
three four yeah oh okay so it's three
four
three four okay and then you're gonna
dig down
five six oh
i don't have the knees for that okay a
little bit so
three four
five six yep shoot down
seven eight
one two
three four five six yep
and then after that that's that dip for
me i'm not here for the dip okay
shimmy
eight
yup
okay eight one two three four five six
show me seven eight yep
five six seven eight one two three four
five six seven eight yes
high five
yeah
pop that toe
yeah kendo job
thank you i thank you again the official
raider at auditions are next week april
16th and the deadline to register is
tomorrow at 5pm kindle in case you oh is
that true in case you're ready yeah you
just head to
raiders.com raiderettes that was so much
fun you grabbed them